Next question, my genes have shown problems with glutathione production.
Should I be measuring glutathione in my labs to see if this is a factor?
Why am I not just supplementing glutathione to help with this?
So, many cancer patients that when we look at your genetics,
you have GST, GLP, a whole bunch of different glutathione G defects.
That's not uncommon.
Well then, why don't we give cancer patients glutathione support?
Okay, so we have to step back again.
So, what does glutathione do?
So, glutathione is your primary intracellular antioxidant.
So, glutathione is an antioxidant.
So, it helps get rid of oxidizing agents inside the cell.
So, if I have deficiencies of glutathione in my cell,
that could actually be a player in why I don't get rid of oxidizing agents well, poisons, toxins.
And they remade the cell and they could end up causing cancer.
So, glutathione deficiencies can actually be a part of the cause of cancer?
Yes, well then why don't we all start taking glutathione?
Because once you have cancer, so once you have cancer, so these cells are rapidly replicating.
They're rapidly replicating cells that are rapidly replicating.
And these rapidly replicating cells are not really healthy cells, not altogether healthy.
They're able to live, but they're not really healthy.
They don't have healthy mitochondria, and that's where you make glutathione.
So, you make glutathione through the metabolic pathways
in the transliferation system of genes that you create glutathione in order to spew it into the intracellular space, the cytoplasm,
where it helps get rid of pathogens, it helps get rid of oxidizing agents.
But, cancer cells, because of their rapid replication, their mitochondria are not nearly as healthy.
They're not producing enough glutathione.
So, they're at this level of self-tox that is near the level of what's called lethal death of a cell.
So, if a cell gets too toxic, meaning it's the oxidative stress
because there's oxidizing agents in their toxins that are in there.
If the oxidizing agents become too great in number, if the oxidative stress of a cell gets too high,
it destroys the cell and kills the cell, and the cell dies.
Your mitochondria prevents that.
So, your mitochondria in the cell are producing glutathione, producing superoxide dispatase,
producing catalysts, always oxidizing agents that are helping in redox reactions to get rid of oxidizing agents.
So, these anti-oxidizing agents are getting rid of oxidizing agents, keeping the cell alive, keeping the cell healthy.
Now, cancer cells, because of their rapid replication, are not producing enough of this,
so they're very close to that threshold.
They put it on a graph, there's a point that you cross that the cell is going to die.
So, cancer cells are close to that threshold of lethal death.
Healthy cells are farther down, you know, are more healthy, that's why they're called healthy cells.
They're making more glutathione, even if you have genetic defects, you're still making glutathione.
So, if you take glutathione as a cancer patient, you could be supplying that which cancer cells need to stay alive.
So, remember, most alternative therapies to kill cancer are oxidizing, they're oxidative.
All standards of care therapies to kill cancer work because they're oxidative.
If you give more poison to the body, you're going to cause more oxidizing, oxidative stress.
If you give radiation to the body, radiation is highly oxidative.
That's how it kills cells, because of the, it's, it's based, you can hit a healthy cell that's making really good mitochondria,
that are really healthy, that are making a lot of glutathione, catalyzed, superoxidous with taste.
You can hit that with radiation, you can kill a healthy cell because you'll cause so much oxidative stress,
even the cell that's making all these antioxidants can't handle it, and the cell dies through cell lysis.
It's just the cell breaks down and dies.
That's what radiation could do to a healthy cell.
Well, they're dosing the radiation so they're trying not to do that to healthy cells though, you can't do that perfectly.
So, you're going to kill healthy cells, but they know that cancer cells will die first.
Why? Because they're closer to that lethal dose, they're closer to that threshold of death.
Now, if you are going to go take a whole bunch of glutathione and antioxidants, what are you doing?
You're kind of helping cancer cells stay alive and we don't want to do that.
So, in general, it's not for everybody because sometimes we do use some antioxidants.
Sometimes we even use glutathione with a cancer patient, but it's rare, honestly.
In general, if we can make generalizations with cancer patients, people who already have a diagnosis of cancer,
should not be taking antioxidants.
Now, if you're in remission and you're doing well, then that's kind of off the table.
But if your cancer is aggressive and growing, you just got diagnosed and you're in the middle of other care,
you don't want to be, if you take antioxidants, you're basically negating the effects of the oxidative therapy that you're trying to do,
whether it's alternative or whether it's standards of care.
So, that's why your oncologist will tell you, do not take antioxidants when you're doing chemotherapy.
Okay, I agree with them. You shouldn't. I don't think you should take antioxidants ever unless they specifically test for you.
So, you do need to be careful, you know, a cancer patient would do things differently than a non-cancer patient.
So, remember that, it depends on what type of morbidity you're dealing with and how you would do that, not just based upon your genes.
It's a long answer for that question, sorry, but hopefully that helps explain that.